la parole est à présent monsieur
philippe paul pour le groupe union pour
un mouvement populaire
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le premier
ministre a annoncé récemment que des
coupes budgétaires fortes étaient
indispensables afin de réduire notre
déficit public conformément aux
exigences de la commission européenne en
le ramenant en dessous des 3% du pib ces
coupes seraient évalués à près de 5
milliards d'euros
visiblement tous les ministères seraient
concernés par ce plan d'économies est le
budget de la défense ne serait pas
épargnée on évoque ainsi de le ramener
de 1,56 du pipa 1,1 c'est sans précédent
ceci provoque de nombreux remous au sein
de nos armées voire un désarroi aussi
bien auprès de nos militaires que des
personnels civils et de l'industrie de
la défense
ce serait tout simplement catastrophique
dans l'hypothèse d'un tel scénario
comment ne pas s'interroger sur le
maintien de la capacité opérationnelle
de nos armées accomplir leur mission
serait tout bonnement impossible et les
fondements mêmes de la défense nationale
voire de notre indépendance remis en
question ceci n'aurait plus de sens nous
n'aurions plus d'armée par ailleurs la
france est intervenue au mali sous
couvert de l'onu avec me semble-t-il le
feu vert des 26 autres pays de l'union
européenne alors que bruxelles demande
instamment à la france de ramener son
déficit public à moins de 3% du pib'
alors que la france est le seul pays
européen à avoir engagé des troupes au
sol certes pour préserver notre pays d'
acte terroriste mais aussi l'europe dans
son ensemble
monsieur le ministre ne considérez vous
pas que la france doit exiger que cette
dépense militaire figure hors contingent
des déficits publics ou à tout le moins
bénéficient d'un déficit particulier nos
partenaires européens doivent comprendre
qu'on ne peut pas avoir l'armée
française et la gratuité de l'armée
française notre armée a un coût il faut
en accepter les conséquences
ainsi dans le cadre des coupes
budgétaires prévues le ministère de la
défense pourrait ne pas être impactés et
pourrait poursuivre efficacement sa
mission en préservant ses matériels ces
personnels civils et militaires et bien
évidemment son industrie de la défense
c'est aussi une question de crédibilité
de nos armées
du rayonnement international et de la
souveraineté de la france je vous
remercie merci monsieur jean yves le
drian
le sénateur vous avez raison de rappeler
le moment où nous nous trouvons dans la
préparation du livre blanc et de la
future loi de programmation militaire
qui sera soumise aux assemblées à
l'automne
il y a des moments de d'arbitrage de
discussions qui ont toujours existé au
moment de la rédaction est
l'aboutissement des lois de
programmation militaire donc
inévitablement des propos sortent ici ou
là dans la presse
annonçant telle ou telle situation
particulièrement difficile j'ai connu ça
sur les bancs de l'assemblée nationale
pendant de nombreuses années
là je le connais de d'un autre point de
vue de la discussion il importe que nous
puissions sortir d'une
difficulté majeure qui consista à la
fois assurer notre souveraineté par la
maîtrise de notre dette et de nos
finances publiques est à la fois notre
souveraineté par l'existence d'une
défense cohérente et efficace et cela se
traduit par des chiffres c'est la
difficulté à laquelle nous nous heurtons
en ce moment et il à laquelle il faudra
donner une un arbitrage final dans les
semaines qui viennent en tout cas votre
proposition
de qui reprend en partie celle de
sénateurs chevènement il ya un instant
de faire en sorte que
l'investissement de défense précisément
parce que c'est de l'investissement ne
soient pas intégrés dans la comptabilité
des déficits publics au niveau européen
a toute ma sympathie
mais je ne suis pas en situation de
pouvoir vous répondre ni à l'un ni à
l'autre mais il ya une cohérence dans le
propos
j'espère que le fait qu'il y ait un
conseil européen de défense à la fin de
cette année et
permettra de poser réellement la place
de l'investissement de défense dans
l'ensemble de la dette européenne et son
efficacité en termes de sécurité mais
aussi de développement économique
merci monsieur philippe paul merci donc
la parole est à présent